Hollow is a pyramid screen that you put
on your smartphone or tablet to project
holographic images and scientists in
taipei have developed a smart tooth
sensor that monitors your oral hygiene
including flossing habits and smoking
and reports them to your dentist Vsauce
Kevin here this is mine well this is a
living creature that looks like a rock
it's completely immobile and eats by
sucking in water and filtering out
microorganisms it reproduces by throwing
clouds of sperm and eggs into the water
to make more living rock babies so yeah
smile drive is gamifying driving
Volkswagen and Google have combined to
create a social app that Awards stickers
for unlocking achievements such as a
100-mile trip or passing someone driving
the same model car as you it works with
any car and even has a feature called
smile cast that creates a travel log of
pictures and posts during your trip and
collects them on a single URL the online
electric vehicle or Olav seeks to make
public transportation cleaner for the
environment by using buses powered by a
power line installed under the road the
battery is only used in emergency
situations with the high efficiency
onboard pickup device using what they
call segmentation control technology
that only powers those segments of the
line the vehicle at that time needs to
move they're still working to make it
more efficient so it can eventually
become commercially available curved
ding is an air bag for bicyclists design
is a master thesis at the University of
lund in Sweden the idea was to create a
protective device for adults who hate
wearing helmets it's worn as a collar
around your neck that can be stylish Lee
hidden with a scarf but inflates to
protect the head in the event of an
accident check out the website for more
created at the Laboratory of intelligent
systems the deployable
air land exploration robot or Daler is a
robot designed to fly and walk on its
wings by using the wings on rough
terrain instead of legs the amount of
mass
is minimized and the lighter-weight
allows for greater flight performance it
has the ability to move on different
surfaces climb high obstacles and
navigate rough terrain on land or on sea
and fibia SAR v sorry
a remote medical care robot is being
developed at Waseda University that will
allow emergency personnel to check for
internal injuries before the patient
gets to the hospital the device can be
attached to the patient while on the way
to the hospital and a doctor can control
it from a remote location
there starting with remote pregnancy
checkup and are hoping to have it used
in practical application within three
years the crab ster CR 200 is a six
legged underwater robot developed by the
Korean Institute of ocean science and
technology it was designed to reach
places that current propel designs can't
because of strong currents giving it the
ability to easily walk along the ocean
floor it takes four people to operate
and uses the front legs that are
equipped with manipulators to grasp
things similar to a real crab and it can
stay on the seafloor for days at a time
an Evo has come up with a way to make
collecting trash more efficient with a
sensor that alerts trash collectors when
a dumpster is full so they're not
wasting time and energy picking up
half-full dumpsters it's called one
collect and he uses real-time fill level
information and advanced algorithms to
calculate the best route so companies
are only collecting the full containers
each day and it's said to save twenty to
forty percent in costs TVI light are
developing intelligent Street lighting
for up to 80% energy savings 50%
maintenance cost reduction lower carbon
footprint and a reduction in light
pollution using plug-and-play wireless
sensors the lights dim to predefined
levels during off-peak hours unless a
human is detected and individual lights
can be remotely monitored and controlled
they also adjust due to weather
conditions and return to normal
operating mode in the event of a system
failure animal jewelry project to show
the fashion industry that fur is alive
German researchers successfully froze
light for a minute
basically they shot a laser through a
crystal which sent its atoms
to two states and then switched off the
first laser with a second beam and
trapped the second laser beam inside
stopping light got that and this is a
huge step in building light based
quantum memory scientists at Wake Forest
University's military Research Center
are developing a method to print skin
cells on to burn wounds by taking the
healthy cells of a patient grown in an
incubator they're able to put them into
an empty cartridge and print them
directly onto the skin a camera and
laser is used to scan the burn and
create a 3d map of the wound and the
computer then tells the printer how many
and what type of skin cells are needed
to fill each area of the world where
they then become new skin cells
University of Michigan engineers have
created stretchable conductors using
polyurethane studded with gold
nanoparticles the material conducts
electricity
even while stretched and it could be
used in the future in flexible
electronics and gentler medical devices
finally crystals is an audio-visual
collaboration using stop-motion
photography that captured crystals
growing under a microscope and it was
made by artist Bruno Levy and DJ Kate
Simcoe
[Music]
I'm gonna leave you with a robot showing
animal-like step reflexes and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
make sure that you follow me on twitter
at Vsauce t wo where I share things that
aren't in videos like this frog holding
a leaf umbrella and other mind-blowing
stuff
so go do it now
[Music]